no
[Música]
qué es lo primero que piensan cuando
escuchan libertad financiera la mayoría
de las personas piensan en viajes
interminables una vida sin
preocupaciones y mucho dinero para
consumir pero la realidad es que están
en lo correcto eso es algo que ofrece la
libertad financiera aunque también se
trata de movilidad del dinero que poseen
las personas y cómo lo administran ya
que les pertenece esto puede verse
comprometido dependiendo del tercero que
utilicen para la gestión y el manejo de
su dinero y de eso vamos a estar
hablando el día de hoy la libertad
financiera fue algo que empecé a
cuestionar desde temprana edad porque
soy venezolana y entendía que en mi país
existía una moneda que es la moneda
nacional el bolívar y que alrededor de
todos nuestros países en latinoamérica
hay diferentes monedas el bolívar me
servía para algunas cosas pero cuando yo
pensaba en adquirir productos que veían
la televisión en el internet o cuando
viajaba debía hacer conversiones que no
siempre resultaban convenientes para mí
entonces ese fue como el primer contacto
de entender cómo varía esto cosa que no
pasaría en personas que viven por
ejemplo en la unión europea o que están
en los eeuu donde generalmente
interactúan con su moneda la mayoría del
tiempo así fue pasando el tiempo y fui
creciendo hasta el momento en que la
situación económica de venezuela se
volvió un poco más tensa y se empezó a
escuchar más la palabra inflación pero
no fue suficiente porque llegamos a la
hiperinflación entonces todas esas
condiciones que la moneda fiduciaria de
mi país tenía desde antes todo ese tipo
de controles y restricciones se fueron
enriqueciendo hasta llegar a lo que
hemos visto en la actualidad habían más
controles y había que buscar más
alternativas para poder encontrar una
opción que me permitiera poder darle
valor al dinero que ganaba día tras día
al trabajar entonces al igual que
muchísimos venezolanos
en la búsqueda de opciones a veces se ve
limitada por el lugar en el que estamos
y por la nacionalidad de nuestros
pasaportes
me puse a interactuar con el mundo de
las cripto monedas en búsqueda de todas
esas opciones y me encontré con una
comunidad increíble que me recibió desde
el primer momento en el que empecé a
investigar esa comunidad de entusiastas
era muy pequeña en ese momento y era
considerada un nicho algunos países
tenían comunidades de este tipo otras
más pequeñas y otros más grandes pero en
el caso de venezuela la comunidad era
bastante interesante era un número que
iba creciendo día tras día y era
bastante interesante que habían personas
en mi ciudad y en otros lugares que
estaban con la misma sed de entender de
qué se trataba este producto entonces de
esa forma
fui interactuando con esta comunidad
para hacerme parte de ellos y allí llegó
un punto en el que yo en aquel entonces
que era una estudiante de psicología me
replanteé que iba a hacer con mi vida
era normal en ese momento mediados del
2017 pensar
y no habían oportunidades en venezuela
que la única opción era salir del país y
dejar a un lado todos los sueños y todas
las metas que uno durante años se
construyó en el país que nos pertenece
pero eso no era una opción para mi yo
pero yo quería investigar y buscar una
alternativa a un plan b dentro de mi
país antes de tomar una decisión y así
fue como llegué a este mundo de las
cripto monedas y me replanteé todo lo
que hacía dejando a un lado de la
psicología y especializando me en el
marketing digital el cual se convirtió
en mi herramienta para poder distribuir
esa información que yo día a día iba
ganando no era una experta ni tampoco lo
soy hoy en día yo opino que las cripto
monedas son un tema muy denso que no le
permite a nadie auto catalogarse de
experto porque todos los días hay una
nueva actualización hay una nueva
información que hasta el más experto del
mundo tiene que aprender desde cero
entonces esto me permitió interactuar
también con la comunidad de balance que
es un exchange global un exchange
vendría siendo lo que es una casa de
cambio que es lo que nosotros conocemos
pero la diferencia entre un exchange y
una casa de cambio es que aquí puedes
intercambiar activos generar ganancias
de acuerdo al comportamiento de esos
activos además de un sinfín de
herramientas que se encuentran ahí
adentro entonces al interactuar con esta
comunidad de la empresa vainas me
encontré con algo más allá de una
empresa para hacerles una idea vaina que
vendría siendo el google de el mundo
block sing y la visión y la vida y
misión que ellos tienen es llevar la
libertad financiera a todos los rincones
del mundo y construir la base de la
tecnología block sing que van a utilizar
muchas personas en un futuro entonces
esa visión de llevar la libertad
financiera era totalmente congruente con
lo que yo estaba buscando como
venezolana porque necesitaba productos
que me aceptaran básicamente entonces
allí encontré una solución en las cripto
monedas y básicamente eso me permitió
seguir en mi país poder trabajar poder
globalizar lo que sabía y además ser
parte de una comunidad que me enseñaba
día a día todo lo referente a finanzas
descentralizadas y finanzas relacionadas
con las cripto monedas ahora bien
específicamente que fue eso que cambió
toda el todo el abanico de oportunidades
que yo tenía en venezuela que fue eso
que aprendí que era diferente que no
muchos venezolanos sabían y que estaban
en ese momento yéndose atrás hacia otro
país y lo voy a resumir en la
accesibilidad
estábamos en una situación en la que la
accesibilidad a productos financieros
tradicionales era muy complicada y el
simple hecho de tener una herramienta
que no va a juzgar o no va a filtrar por
mi nacionalidad mi raza mi edad o
simplemente la situación financiera era
algo bastante relevante esta herramienta
me permitía enviar y recibir dinero sin
importar dónde estuviese la otra
contraparte esto fue algo que me
permitió al igual que muchas personas
sacarle un provecho y un beneficio y
encontrar nuevas oportunidades tanto en
venezuela como en cualquier parte del
mundo no es casualidad que la mayoría de
los países donde el crecimiento de
cripto monedas ha sido exponencial sean
países que han sido afectados por crisis
económicas o inflación esto no lo veo
como algo negativo a pesar de seguir
viendo noticias día tras día sobre la
situación lo veo como un reto que
vivimos todos y que tenemos que utilizar
para tomar lo mejor y construir el país
que nosotros deseamos en el caso de
venezuela nos encontramos entre los
países que más adopción de cripto
monedas posee tenemos un sinfín de
titulares en los medios de comunicación
cripto y tradicional sobre cómo
venezuela es un caso de estudio sobre
cómo las personas han empezado a
utilizar cripto monedas para mejorar
significa
y su calidad de vida esto es algo que me
gusta muchísimo resaltar como venezolana
porque normalmente las personas hablan
de que los mayores avances se realizan
en asia en europa o en los eeuu y yo
digo que no lo estamos viviendo frente a
nosotros y es importante resaltar toda
esa información es importante resaltar
todo lo que estamos construyendo en
venezuela porque eso es algo que tiene
valor y que nos da valor a todos
nosotros como venezolanos además de
esperanza de que podemos tener un
sistema que nos pertenece porque las
cripto monedas y el bitcoin son de cada
persona entonces hablando ya más en lo
que han hecho de referencia a los medios
de comunicación el portal china análisis
ha catalogado venezuela varias veces
como uno de los países que ha tenido
mayor adopción de cripto moneda en el
año 2020 estuvimos en el tercer lugar de
los países que más utilizan cripto
monedas y en el año 2021 en el número
siete a pesar de que hemos bajado en ese
rango nos mantenemos como el primero en
latinoamérica
más uno de los que manejan mayor volumen
en transacciones personas a personas
pero esto no solamente se ha destacado
en la región de latinoamérica sino
también en áfrica el ejemplo de áfrica
es similar son países que han pasado por
situaciones económicas rudas donde las
personas han tenido que buscar otro tipo
de sistemas financieros que le permitan
acceder
a un manejo más óptimo de sus fondos
allá tenemos la cifra de que en el año
2020 se recibieron alrededor de 684
millones de dólares y en el año 2021
esta cifra se dobló al ser 2 billones de
dólares los que recibieron en
transacciones pero es una persona pero
bien que son esas transacciones persona
a persona
pierce to peer o p2p
básicamente son dos personas que
intercambian fondos la mayoría de los
venezolanos han hecho este tipo de
transacciones sin saberlo es básicamente
cuando vas y le compras dólares a una a
un hermano a un vecino oa un amigo
a diferencia de hacerlo dentro de una
plataforma es que hay un tercero o hay
un sistema que se encarga de que las dos
personas realicen ese intercambio de
manera efectiva a realizar ese
intercambio de manera efectiva las
personas liberan el dinero a su
contraparte y la contraparte lo recibe
en estos sistemas se puede dejar
comentarios para crear reputación y de
esa forma hacer un ambiente más seguro
para este tipo de transacciones sin
tener que contar con un banco o con una
casa de cambio tradicional este tipo de
transacciones personas personas que les
mencioné que crecieron en áfrica no son
el único caso de uso pero si son
relevante dentro del ecosistema de
vainas porque la mayoría de las personas
que se acercan las cripto monedas no va
motivada por el trading que normalmente
es una palabra que retumba mucho cuando
se habla de bitcoin se ha notado una
tendencia hacia el ahorro y hacia la
protección del valor de los activos
específicamente en estos países pero
además de hablar
y protección de las finanzas personales
o de las finanzas de ciertas empresas
también se han utilizado cripto monedas
para apoyar iniciativas que ayudan a
personas en el caso de la campaña en
sharp que se realizó en nigeria esta
campaña fue un boom global ya que la
vimos en los timeline de celebridades
como jack dorsey y rihanna donde se
manifestaban en contra de la brutalidad
policial que había en este país esta
campaña le permitió a personas de todo
el mundo apoyar la causa utilizando
bitcoin y lo bueno de utilizar bitcoin
es que es completamente transparente
porque es un libro en blanco y es un
libro donde se van escribiendo todas las
transacciones y cualquier persona en
cualquier lugar del mundo puede ver que
está sucediendo
siempre y cuando se llegará a pesar de
que al mismo tiempo se garantiza la
confidencialidad y el anonimato de las
personas que están involucradas en esas
transacciones entonces eso hace
muchísimo más transparente y el proceso
de recolección de fondos en este tipo de
actividades ahora bien ya sabemos que el
uso de las cripto monedas ha destacado
en venezuela ha destacado en muchísimas
regiones del mundo pero como ser parte
de todo este movimiento
lo principal que van a buscar o que van
a encontrar al buscarlo en google o en
cualquier sitio es crear una cuenta
crear una billetera recibe dinero
etcétera pero yo diría que lo importante
de todo esto es reconocer la
responsabilidad individual de cada
persona qué tiene que ver esto bueno es
un cambio de paradigma el que estamos
realizando al dejar a un lado un sistema
financiero tradicional y al entregarle
toda la confianza de nuestro dinero a un
sistema descentralizada en qué consiste
esto entender que no hay un tercero de
confianza y si hay un tercero de
confianza por medio de alguna wallet
centralizada o billeteras centralizadas
comprender que nosotros somos los
responsables de investigar y de saber a
quién le estamos entregando
los fondos entonces hacer esa primera
investigación es primordial dentro de la
filosofía de bitcoin que pueden leer
rápidamente en menos de 20 minutos
porque a través del libro blanco de
bitcoin van a encontrar toda la
filosofía referente a todo este producto
es transparente es descentralizado es
libre y eso es algo que tenemos que
tomar en cuenta cuando usamos este tipo
de cripto moneda en general porque hay
personas que quieren entrar a este
movimiento para vender ideas para vender
productos y para engañar personas y no
es así cuando entendemos realmente qué
es lo que está escrito en todo este
código que es invariable y que todo el
mundo puede ver tal y como es entendemos
que este tipo de conductas no no tienen
vida porque todo está claro y a la vista
en general además de personas que hacen
esto para
distorsionar lo que es una cripto moneda
hay muchas cripto monedas en el mundo la
última que revise habían 14.000 pero
estoy segura que en este momento ese
número ayuda aumentando aumentando por
qué sucede esto porque cualquier persona
puede crear una cripto moneda y va y por
eso la responsabilidad de cada usuario
tiene que centrarse en entender cuál es
el producto en dónde está colocando su
dinero
afortunadamente bitcoin que fue creado
en el año 2009 ha pasado por todo un
proceso que le añade confianza y le
añade seguridad a ese proyecto que se
plasmó a través de un libro blanco que
fue escrito por satoshi nakamoto que en
este momento no sabemos quién es y
tampoco sabremos quién es porque puede
que sea un grupo de personas puede que
sea otra persona pero él o ellos optaron
por ser completamente anónimos y dejar
su contribución al mundo a través del
bitcoin entonces ya entendemos y ya
sabemos cómo ser parte de todo esto ya
sabemos la parte más grande del resto
será simplemente utilizarlo porque es
algo bastante natural la verdad que
todos empezamos a utilizar dinero
y nadie en ningún momento dijo yo voy a
ver qué es un banco central yo voy a ver
quién imprimió esta moneda voy a ver por
qué colocaron este símbolo patrio en esa
moneda eso no sucedió y yo creo que en
el futuro eso no va a suceder con
bitcoin pero la gente simplemente lo va
a utilizar pero afortunadamente estamos
en una etapa donde apenas han pasado
pocos años y tenemos el lujo de vivirlo
a temprana edad y también ver todo el
proceso que ha ocurrido desde que se
creó hasta que se adoptó y así han ido
sucediendo cosas impresionantes
alrededor de todo el mundo ya vemos como
las naciones están literalmente
compitiendo por quién será el próximo en
adoptarlo oficialmente el salvador dio
un primer paso hace unos meses al
declarar bitcoin como una moneda de
curso legal pero qué es lo que buscan
las grandes naciones las instituciones y
las empresas al incluir bitcoin dentro
de sus inversiones o simplemente
declarar la moneda de curso legal
estas empresas y estos gobiernos buscan
básicamente
incrementar la confianza de sus mercados
e incrementar sus reservas y disminuir
la bancarización por decir algunos de
los factores que están mejorando pero
bueno vamos a tener que esperar para
saber cuál será el próximo país que lo
va a lograr dentro del portal coin
market cap se están realizando
votaciones donde las personas están
opinando y haciendo suposiciones de
cuáles van a ser los próximos países con
más de 300 mil votos paraguay está como
el segundo y le sigue venezuela pero la
realidad es que lo sabremos próximamente
cuando sea una realidad lo que ha
sucedido durante todos estos años es
historia y lo importante es que hemos
sido parte de esa historia sabemos que
existe un sistema descentralizado y una
moneda madre que es bitcoin a la cual
podemos acceder y dejar a un lado todas
esas restricciones que los sistemas
tradicionales han impuesto sobre
nosotros
a pesar de que desde el 2009 hasta el
bitcoin ha muerto en número en numerosas
situaciones ha subido y ha bajado de
precio ha sido la moneda o el activo con
mayor desempeño en los últimos tiempos
entonces por más que hemos visto a
políticos gobiernos personalidades
empresas y muchos medios más declararse
en contra de bitcoin luego los hemos
tenido que ver retractarse de sus
palabras y entrar a este movimiento
porque el poder que bitcoin le ha dado a
las personas ha sido tan grande que
simplemente no podrán callarlo